[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is melody McPhee
so and today we're gonna be talking
about the secrets of top performing
DevOps teams you can ask questions
anytime on the platform and we have
Googlers on standby to answer them so
let's get started thank you so much for
being here jazz I'm so excited to spend
this time today learning about your
research and high performing DevOps
teams and to share some examples from
Google's experience thanks very much for
having me it's a pleasure and an honor
to be here great so let's dive right in
we're gonna talk a little bit about
defining DevOps torinte us all around
what's included in it we're gonna dig
into some of the fascinating research
from door around DevOps performance
we're also going to talk about some
findings and how we balance speed with
stability in terms of software
development dig into how we can all
improve as a community as both
individuals teams in a community and
then finish up talking a little bit
about the role that open-source is
playing in DevOps
so what is DevOps there's no agreed
definition of DevOps I'm sure you have a
different one from me somehow mine has
made it onto the slide so I like to
think of DevOps in terms of the goals
we're trying to achieve and the people
who are trying to achieve those goals so
I like to talk about a community of
practice dedicated to building evolving
and operating rapidly changing secure
resilient systems at scale so that's
what we're trying to do it's hard we
haven't worked out yet we're all
improving all the time there's three key
areas that I think we need to think
about and our research covers and then
we're going to talk about today number
one is organizational culture we're
spending a lot of time talking about
that technical practices and then
finally management practices which is
also important if you're going to
achieve the kind of things we talked
about so as developers and operators
really focused on how do we take that
idea and get it out to the user
community so that they can get value out
of it and I think it's it's it's
interesting to think about where we are
in terms of how DevOps is enable
to do that so we have the idea of taking
that idea and understanding what the
requirements are of the business like
writing down what features do we think
we need to actually go you know fingers
on the keyboard develop code around and
there used to be this wall right of
throwing requirements back and forth
between the business and development
well agile really helped us solve that
that wall and break it down but as we
both know there's another wall that has
existed between development and
operations so once the code is done it
needs to be operated out in production
and there's a wall that exists of sort
of throwing throwing throwing the
release over so to speak DevOps is
helping us break down that wall and help
increase the velocity and the practices
around moving from development writing
building and testing code into operating
at scale from production with the intent
that as we increase that cycle time and
improve the reliability words of we're
delivering better quality results out to
the market and out to the users so the
research again fascinating to see the
impact of DevOps on overall performance
so software delivery performance there's
a there's some information that comes
out around the difference between high
performers and elite performers and we
see from your research that elite
performers are 1.5 3 times more likely
to exceed their business outcomes and
those outcomes are measured by
productivity they're measured by
profitability by market share real
concrete positive measures in terms of
getting the software out to the
end-users on the market it's fascinating
to see that impact yeah absolutely and I
think that has been one of the big
outcomes from my research for the last
few years seeing there has a business
impact also just having a way to measure
DevOps performance so Google of a
Seabury metrics focus we found a valid
and reliable way to measure software
delivery performance which helps us also
understand how to change performance as
well we can do statistical research on
the factors that improve performance and
again we'll talk about that today so how
do we measure performance two kinds of
measures
measures of three per how fast we're
going so deploy frequency how frequently
we deploy and then Li time for changes
how fast can we go from version control
code in version control to production
then to stability measures so time to
restore service if there's an incident
or an outage or service degradation how
quickly can we restore service and then
change fail rate is kind of a measure of
the quality of our release process when
you push out or change what percentage
of the time do we need to roll forward
or or back and remediate and if there's
kind of one thing to take away from this
it's high performers and not trading off
speed instability we kind of have this
idea that going faster means breaking
things that's not the case consistently
over five years we find the high
performance a better at throughput and
stability and late performers are worse
throughput stability and it's
interesting when you think about it you
have to come back and fix the problem so
you want to decrease the amount of time
for that mean time to resolve right
exactly I mean fight is inevitable with
operating complex systems you've got to
take that into consideration absolutely
so here's what we found this year every
year we do cluster analysis and we find
groups within our data that behave in
similar ways this year we found four
groups a low performing group that's
releasing pretty infrequently once
between once a week and once a month
their lis time for changes is measured
in months
takes them a long time to restore
service as well and they're changed fail
rate is between forty six and sixty
percent so that's at the bottom and
again doing badly all of those measures
and then up at the top end we have these
elite performers that's seven percent of
our total they're deploying on demand so
they have multiple deployments per day
it takes some less than an hour to get
changes from version control to
production if they need to remediate
because there's a problem they can do
that in less than an hour and and we
think that's because they able to use
their normal process for remediation as
well there's no special emergency
process where you skip a bunch of the
testing you can just use your regular
process and their change trail rates are
really low they have a really
high-quality release process this year
we extended our measure of performance
to also include availability so
availability obviously your users can
access your service and also you can
make promises about the availability of
your systems
so say that your users your customers
can rely on them again we find that
people are not making trade-offs they're
not going faster and availability is
going down in fact quite the opposite
and eat performers in terms of software
delivery performance are three point
five five times more likely to have
strong availability practices so these
things all go together so let's talk a
little bit about that balancing of speed
with stability because we know that
users expectations around availability
are increasing so as an end user if I go
to use a particular app or system I
expect it to be up I expect it to be
available so I just wanted to start by
grounding in the fact that you know
youyou us as a devops community as
software teams make decisions around
availability and I think we need to
remember that perfection is unrealistic
as far as I know keep me honest here no
human has ever created a perfectly
reliable system and if we look out to
nature we see the same thing you know
competitive pressures evolution of
systems perfect reliability is not the
best target so let's talk a little bit
about why and I think it comes back to
perfection can be wasteful so your users
of your application in your system have
many other dependencies this is the
reality with with infrastructure and and
cloud infrastructure and your users
experience reliability as all of those
dependencies together of which your
service is one so it's important to come
back to thinking about the expectations
of your users and the overall
expectation of those dependencies and
your understanding of them they may not
notice I'm gonna give an example here in
a second they may not notice the
difference in adding two nines to your
of availability but they're probably
gonna notice the cost so what is the
goal around setting these availability
and reliability targets it's really to
make our users happy they expect this
this level of availability and we as
devops teams have to balance the
features that we're giving to the users
with their expectations of reliability
so we want to set those reliability
targets to be
in line with the other dependencies that
the users have accepted and to
understand that insufficient reliability
it makes unhappy users right our goal is
to make our users happy but if we have
excessive reliability we're gonna waste
opportunities to launch features and to
release at high velocity as Jaz
mentioned so think about that the
trade-off that's being made there and
there's a bunch of factors that can go
into this users have different
expectations around you know service
levels that are set there's things that
we can consider around expectations for
paid services versus free services what
it what what's happening with
competitors in this market what are they
setting their reliability targets and
always to come back to the cost side of
this there's a human cost effort and
time to hit certain reliability targets
and availability targets so we need to
we need to consider that in the
decisions that we make as DevOps teams
and at Google we found that this
objective metric called an error budget
helps balance availability with velocity
so you take up you know hundred percent
you set your availability target and you
have your error budget so that product
management at developers and essary are
all working off the same metric and
there's flexibility as we'll see if you
have error budget remaining maybe you
were going to take more risks on the
release side having that understanding
of how your service is operating so this
is an example you can see here and I
just want to call out the difference if
you have an availability target of three
nines you have around you know you can
see per year per quarter thirty days in
this slide but you can see you have
about two point one six hours of allowed
unavailability right so that's downtime
that's that's time that your users are
not gonna be able to use your
application if you wanted to target five
nines which for some systems that may be
correct you've only got a minute point
three zero I mean that's terrifying it's
terrifying
so we really want
come back - you can set this metric make
sure it's in line with the dependencies
make sure it's in line with the user
expectations and know what what the
trade-offs are going to be because that
level of service may be required but it
comes at it comes at a cost so what are
the benefits of creating these error
budgets you know we're gonna talk about
culture in a little bit but creating
common incentives and a shared fate or a
shared responsibility around uptime is
so critical and we found at Google that
between developers and a Suri's this is
the way that we balance innovation and
reliability and you know the other
aspect of this that I find really
important is that the developers become
self-policing so the operators you know
that wall between development and
operations that we talked about just
really break this down where everyone
has the common goal around uptime and
developers know where where those
trade-offs can be made maybe where we
can take more risks around future
velocity but everyone's on the same page
everyone's oriented around that metric
and I have examples within my
development team where you know we were
all looking at the air budget and seeing
where we stand for the quarter and
making sure that we're falling within
our availability targets super important
okay so we talked a bit about what's
important to measure and how you can
think about those measurements and use
them to drive changes in behavior we're
gonna talk a bit about how you actually
get better at this stuff what are the
things that you can do if you're not
doing so well in terms of performance
that can shift you to the left in this
case and shifting left is going to be a
big theme so three things we're going to
talk about and that we've measured over
the last five years technical practices
culture and management so obviously a
lot of the focus of DevOps is on
automation you're going to talk about
some of the tools that you use at google
automation is obviously very important
and in our data this year we finds that
elite performers are have have high
levels of automation lower levels of
manual work this is interesting this is
something you can only measure through
surveys you can't look at system data
and find out how much manual work is
being done you can only find out by
asking people
see the low performers are doing much
more manual work when they're doing
configuration management deployments
testing change approval process than our
elite performers are doing and that
should be no surprise one of the things
that lead performers do is find ways to
automate things that are repetitive the
algorithmic but these numbers are not
zero it's important to bear in mind that
there will always be manual work there's
always going to be things that you're
going to have to do continuous delivery
there's this misconception that some
people have that it's about automating
everything that we're going to get rid
of testers for example that absolutely
not the case you still there still
manual work to be done exploratory
testing and usability testing that's
critically important the other thing to
point out about this is that you can't
just take complex painful processes and
automate them you have to simplify so
there's a simplification patient piece
in terms of architecture processes that
has to go hand in hand with automation I
think it's you you found here that we
talked about toil a lot and there's many
dimensions of toil but you can clearly
see how automation is coming into play
from low performers to elite performers
to really make time to address the toil
and to factor those improvements back
into the into the workflow yeah and
actually it's not in the presentation
but in the report and we look at the
amount of time that people are spending
on new feature development versus non
value add work like fixing problems and
we find that elite performers 50% that
their time is spent on a value-add work
work versus toil so it's an interesting
reflection of something that you
observed at Google right so how do you
actually improve your performance from a
technical perspective well over the five
years that we've been doing this we
found a whole bunch of different
practices obviously there's their
classic continuous delivery practices of
good configuration management and
version control continuous integration
automation around the test and deploy
process this year we also looked at
continuous testing which is we're not
just going to automate some of our
testing we're also going to build
testing work into the software delivery
lifecycle have testers working alongside
developers testing process monitoring
and observability turns out those things
are in
and obviously you spend a lot of time
thinking about that and doing that at
Google so that has a big impact on your
ability to deliver with speed and
stability building database management
and security into the delivery process
again shifting left on that stuff and
we'll talk about security in just a
little bit those things together all
impact software delivery performance
positively and availability
interestingly they also positively
impact culture so we'll talk about
culture in a bit but how do you change
culture well you change it by changing
how people work and how they behave in
technical practices they're a big part
of that also want to point out these
technical practices reduce deployment
pain and they also reduce team burnout
so obviously we want to avoid teams that
are working crazy hours and feeding a
lot of stress that's that's bad for the
humans and that results in bad outcomes
these practices can reduce burnout as
well it's so important so I wanted to
share an example of that I think
demonstrates a lot of the principles
that and and findings that you found so
Google invest significantly in code
review you can see a stat here about
20,000 code reviews a day we do this as
a way to invest in education among the
developers and operators that are
writing code and trying to get those
features out to our end-users but it's a
it's a significant investment in quality
right want quality of code because we
want to find the issues before were
further along in the deployment pipeline
and you know we want to find it
definitely before it gets out to the
end-users as much as we possibly can so
we've invested a lot in automation
around code reviews and the intention
behind this is to have that automation
free up the humans time to focus on the
content and the quality and the
improvements that can be made to the
code so we've incorporated things we
call robo robo reviews or about code
reviews where we're looking for checks
and tests and analyzers that can do
things like enforce the style and
formatting because we know that
increases readability and it makes it
easier for the humans to interact with
the code compiler based analyzers to
look for a problematic patterns in the
codes
that we can prompt the developers and
operators to look at that and take
action based on it custom analyzers
we've created a internal community and
ecosystem around custom analyzers that
different engineering teams can adopt
and then if those are valuable other
teams can adopt them so you're creating
a community around these types of
analysis and then finally building all
of this build and test into the CI
system so that the code we're catching
we're running the test and we're
catching issues in the code and we're
surfacing those in the code reviews as
fast as we possibly can to catch it
before it incurs the cost in the rest of
the development workflow and I find it I
mean really fascinating that you
invested so much effort into making the
code review process smooth and easy one
of the things we talked about is working
in small batches developers being able
to make small changes and push them in
and that is it's critical to have a code
review process that is simple and smooth
so that you can do that very frequently
yeah I think there's there's definitely
some interesting points there around
taking risk and knowing that the
automation is there and then doing those
small batches to be able to release us
frequently as the team's possibly can
yep
yeah so beyond code review we want to
build automation into the entire
workflow and it's great because
developers and operator just continue to
raise the bar on the level of automation
definitely shows up in the elite
performers and how they're spending
their time so if we start and we just go
around the circle we have cloud source
repositories to help with version
control to present search and different
levels of insight into the code so
fingers on the keyboard writing code
then we go with two three and four into
the build test and deploy pipeline so
cloud build will talk about security in
a second but the ability to build and
test your application and then using
container registry be able to then take
it into spinnaker and open source
deployment system to release your code
high quality code to the underlying
platform whether that's compute engine
kubernetes engine or app engine but we
can't stop there right so we have
systems like stack driver that are
monitoring alerting and logging to
look for if we deployed something and
there's an increased rate of errors
we're gonna make sure we take a look the
operators can take a look at that and
take action and we actually have ways to
then bring that back to code that exists
in the repo and then we go around again
to fix the issue so I think this the
cycle of continuous improvement within
sites and then building that automation
into the workflow really makes the
developers and operators feel like these
systems have their back and then they're
gonna focus on you know the high value
content related tasks that they need to
do with the code yeah a service and I
love the fact you've got all these
feedback loops going back to developers
from all the different parts of the
delivery pipeline here that's really
great
great so security
finally we made it we all have to care
about it yeah I'm you know this is
something that I often say you can't
build stuff that you know doesn't have
security and performance and have the
magic DevOps Pixies come after
definitely and wave their magic wand and
fix the security and performance and
availability you have to build it in so
we find in our research building
security into the software delivery
process shifting left improves not just
software livery performance but also the
quality of your security so it improves
both outcomes when we gather the data
this year we find that elite performers
are building security in and they can do
security reviews and remediate any
problems they find in the space of days
whereas low performers are taking weeks
not just to conduct security reviews but
also to fix the problems that they find
when they're doing them so that's a real
problem and a real constraint for many
people in their delivery process so what
do we want to do we want to build
security and by running security tests
as part the deployment pipeline as you
talked about and I think going to talk
about a bit more and making it easy for
developers to consume libraries that are
known to be good obviously if there's a
CVE discovered in the library you want
to be able to get a fixed version of
that and get that out into production as
quickly as he possibly can another
instance where time to restore services
is really important new times are really
important make sure that your tool
trains and your processes are helping
you help developers build security in as
well yeah
the the timeliness of security reviews
the ability for the developers to react
and then where we go next is building
out automation and to help them from the
beginning so just some examples again
Jaz talked about you know shifting left
we're writing code but then we need to
build it and as part of that build the
you know the code may be changed by
multiple people on the team
multiple dependencies so we've built a
vole nur ability scanning into cloud
build to detect those issues so that we
know ahead of time before we get further
down in the deployment pipeline where
there's a problem we're also building in
policy creation and enforcement to give
the power and control to the developers
and operators and to software teams to
be able to enforce certain policies like
binary authorization so if you look at
the just these two pieces and I think
these are really the beginning we're
getting to the point where we have
something that's trusted that we can
then deploy and really understand that
this is this is a high quality release
that's going out because what we want to
know is if there's something that's
untrusted if there is a school security
vulnerability and empower the DevOps
teams to act on that before they get
further in the pipeline so we're
tightening that loop around security to
address those issues long before it
makes it to the end users yeah I know
that I mean security is so critical for
Google you have systems like email that
you know state actors are trying to
interfere with so it's a great example
of how actually these practices really
help with improving security so
management practices so management is
important as well obviously over the
years we found that lean approaches to
product management are really critical
at improving performance and culture and
those organizational outcomes we talked
about profitability market share quality
customer satisfaction what we find is
working in small batches developing
small feature increments prototypes
pushing those out to production getting
feedback from real users and then
iterating rapidly to build things that
deliver the outcomes you want for your
users in your organization enabling
teams to experiment it's not we're not
throwing requirements over the wall to
order-taking development teams and
development teams actually
have input in so what gets built I mean
you have these highly trained
experienced professionals building
software they have ideas and opinions
and and it's crazy not to leverage that
yeah
so we find that those practices together
positively impacts culture performance
organizational performance we saw a
culture for a lot I just want to quickly
dive into how we measured culture and
again project Aristotle at Google we
confirm some of the findings from that
as well we have this model of culture
that comes from a sociologist called Ron
westrom he's looking at safety outcomes
in aviation and healthcare so safety
critical fields and he has this typology
where he divides organizations up as to
whether they're pathological
power-oriented bureaucratic or
generative or mission or performance
oriented and you can probably if you're
following along at home here work out
where you fit on this pretty easily it's
kind of quite a visceral model and
there's six different axes here that he
looks at the extent to which people
cooperate between different parts the
organization how do we deal with people
who bring us bad news do we train people
to bring us bad news so that we can act
on it rapidly before something really
bad happens do we ignore people who
bring us bad news or do we you know
shoot the messenger and say you know how
dare you tell me this this thing that I
don't anyone to know about how do we
deal with responsibilities do we avoid
them because we know we're going to get
into trouble when things go wrong or do
we believe that we succeed or fail as a
team and share risks because we trust
each other
how do we deal with bridging between
different parts of the organization and
then two things that are really two
different sides of the same coin I think
how do we deal with failure and the
extent to which were able to innovate so
failure here does that lead to blaming
people you know melody you mess this up
you're a terrible person or you know
we're building complex systems failure
is inevitable thank you for helping us
find this problem that we can now do
something about that's right and that's
important if you're going to innovate
innovate by definition is doing things
that have never been done before so
there's a high risk of failure whenever
you're innovating if people are worried
that they're going to get punished when
things go wrong they're not going to
innovate yeah so yeah
that please you you bring up so many
important points I mean humans were the
ones writing the software right we're
writing the code we're operating the
service we have to trust each other
right so I think DevOps has been
extremely powerful and starting to break
down those walls and take the practices
and the tools in the automation behind
it and really help to reinforce the
trust between the individuals because
this is software it's not gonna be
perfect there's gonna be bugs there's
gonna be issues how we work together in
those situations is such an important
part of that yeah and our research backs
up exactly what you said which is that
the way you impact culture is through
implementing these practices these
technical practices these management
practices so a couple of things that we
found this year in terms of impacts in
culture we talked about ascetical and
management practices we also found that
retrospectives are really important
retrospectives learning reviews
post-mortems these kinds of activities
impact culture positively they also help
create a climate for learning a climate
for learning is when organizations treat
learning as an investment or something
that we should make sure people have the
resources and time to be able to do not
some kind of afterthought well you know
do your learning on the weekend so that
you can you know work the number hours
you're supposed to work in your time
card so what we find is that elite
performers a 1.5 times more likely to
consistently hold retrospective and
learning reviews and also critically to
use the outputs of those activities to
improve their work yeah yeah I you you
bring up so many important points from
the research I just wanted to share at
Google we see a lot of these principles
in action and I just want to highlight a
couple of them so the first part is how
do you how do you take the personal out
of it look at the data look at the code
look at the logs look at the
dependencies look at traces understand
error rates developers and operators
come back to the data to guide those
decisions how can we learn the most that
we possibly can about what's happening
in the system to fix the problem having
a shared fate and collaborating between
developers and operators so we we shared
an example today about air budgets and
how developers and sres work to
around air budgets getting everyone
oriented around what we're trying to do
and why we're trying to do it is such an
important part it affects communication
and affects trust and and how we work
together transparency so everyone sees
the same thing we have tools in writing
code and running build and tests in our
code review that we highlighted a little
bit today that makes all that data
visible right so we're not withholding
information or trying to control
information and you're in your cultural
observations so that people can take
action to resolve the issue as quickly
as possible and you know near and dear
to my heart
blameless post-mortems my development
team does them every week we sit down we
learn we talk about what happened we
understand what measures we took we
think about not just technical fixes but
process fixes and we take away a set of
two do's that we hold ourselves
accountable for and again like this is
just reinforcing that we're gonna take
risks we're gonna do things that haven't
been done before but we're gonna learn
from it right we're all here to learn we
all make mistakes perfectionist as I
said before unrealistic and we're
building that trust between the
developers and operators by doing that
yeah and I just want to put in a quick
plug for the Google SRA book and Google
sre workbook that just came out last
month I believe and there's a lot of
discussion about how you do those those
kinds of activities at Google which is
really great absolutely so open source
obviously open source is a big deal at
Google and you contribute a lot we found
that actually only 58% of responders
said they were using open source
components libraries and platforms
extensively that was a surprise for me I
expected it to be more more and I wonder
the extent to which people aren't
considering all the layers in the stack
I mean it's kind of inconceivable to me
that anyone would not be using open
source somewhere whether it's in terms
of the operating system the libraries
they're consuming and the other pieces
of the ecosystem infrastructure and so
forth but this is what the data says 50
percent agreed that their team planned
to expand use of open source software
and we find that it's correlated with
quite
performance elite performers are 1.75
times more likely to make extensive use
of open source components so at Google
cloud platform we're very committed to
investing in open source Google has one
of the highest contribution rates to
open source we believe in the in the
power and influence of open source and
you can see some examples here of recent
open source contributions scaffold saw
some issues that existed in the local
build test and deploy workflow
wanted to help you know influence and
create solutions their kubernetes we
know that the adoption of containerized
workflows is significantly increasing
significant community there in terms of
contributions
you know sto and many others you know
when I talk to customers and developers
and operators there's such power and
being able to contribute and influence
how the open source product is evolving
and the community and power around that
is so significant for enterprise
customers not wanting to be locked in
right
there's notice this change in the last
five to ten years around and the
acceptance of open source and it's it's
just it's really exciting to see that
yeah a new Google cloud platform you
have a commitment open source is right
yes we do we're committed to being the
open cloud and that doesn't just mean
open source it means open api's and an
open platform for developers and
partners and customers to be able to
collaborate together so just to wrap up
we've we've shared a lot about doors
latest research report on
high-performing teams there's an
opportunity for us as software teams to
use throughput and stability and
availability to measure our performance
and we've seen the impact of that in the
research that just shared today
DevOps it matters whether it's
commercial or non-commercial right so
we're seeing with the advent of open
source we're seeing with enterprise
goals that are being set DevOps
practices are starting to be employed
more so than I think they ever have give
you an example of err budgets and tried
to highlight how that common metric can
help reinforce availability and a shared
understanding of availability and how
to have both feature velocity and
stability and availability and then with
the right set of technical management
and cultural practices can help DevOps
help create trust among the humans that
are developing the software and increase
velocity and business outcomes for those
teams so yeah I just gonna say I mean
we've only scratched the surface of the
report if you want to go download it you
can go to bit ly slash 2018
- DevOps - report I think we'll put the
URL with webcast as well but I mean it
there's a lot of material in there we've
just kind of highlighted some of the key
points today there is I have to go back
and reread it another time so thank you
so much jazz for being here thank you so
much for your the research that you've
provided and for sharing this all with a
DevOps community thanks so much for
having me thank you so stay tuned for
the live Q&A we'll be back in less than
a minute
you
thanks for coming back we're here now to
answer some live questions from the
audience I'm melody and this is jazz so
let's see I let's just get into it
okay so one question any nuggets of
advice to give to someone carrying out
an agile slash DevOps transformation at
a huge bank so I hear this a lot you
know we're regulated its financial
services working in government or
something it's hard so I want to
acknowledge yes it is hard however we do
find in the research and that's in the
report this year there is no difference
no statistically significant difference
between verticals in terms of your
ability to do this stuff we find
regulated organizations large
organizations in the high performing in
the elite performing groups so you can
do this we've seen continuous delivery
done with mainframes so it's hard I
think the advice is probably don't do
the whole organization at once find some
part of the organization that you can
practice on that you can start learning
and then take the things that work and
move them out through the organization
except that there's a bunch of things
that won't work and that's okay because
you're learning as you go along so my
advice is go for it
but except that it's gonna be hard it's
gonna take a bunch of time don't let
that stop you from starting yeah
absolutely when I talk to financial
institutions or institutions in
healthcare this this question keeps
coming up and I think you know my advice
would be similar to to just start with a
small piece and really gain some
momentum with that because we know if
you look out to open source and look at
some of the research we've done
developers look to other developers for
help and guidance and when you have this
success on maybe a particular area of
your pipeline if you if you start with C
ICD it can be it can go viral and other
developers were learn about it they look
to it as an example and then they will
help make it better so start small
get some momentum going and then you can
really build from that because if the
culture takes time to change right we've
seen that it takes reinforcement of
practice
takes development of tools which takes
time and that shift between how how the
humans work together within whatever
company is that that you're that you're
working working on and I think you know
huge organizations are very
heterogeneous you will typically find in
an organization that all the answers are
there yeah they're just scattered around
in all different parts the organization
so find the people who are doing the
good stuff and and find ways to spread
that right yeah I've also advised you
know internal hackathons and developer
community events within financial
institutions where you bring the
developers together to talk about the
ideas that they have and some of the
changes that they want to make internal
develop stays conferences exactly so can
you talk a bit more about misguided
performers that was something the the
report mentioned yes and someone asked
about outsourcing as well yeah these
kind of things are related so and when
we did the cluster analysis we found
this this group that is kind of similar
to the live performers they're releasing
very infrequently but their time to
restore is really long it's like
multiple months to restore and we kind
of thought there must be something weird
going on with like is a data right we
check their data that's what it told us
yeah and if you look in real life you
can you can see things like this
happening so I mean healthcare.gov was a
good example where it I mean that they
got serviced somewhat restored quite you
know in the space of days but it took
them months to actually fix all the
systemic problems in the infrastructure
and fully restore service to the level
that was expected
yeah and required of that service and
security vulnerabilities if someone
hacks into your system it could easily
take you months to pull all that out and
fix all those problems fix any data
problems so now when you think about it
that that's real and we see it reflected
in the data the message is don't assume
that going slowly is going to save you
because if you go very slowly and
release very infrequently and finger
you're going to prevent all the problems
by doing all this very careful
prevention work that's going to hit you
when something actually goes wrong
because it's going to really impact your
ability to fix that rapidly so that's
what the data says we also found a
strong correlation between muscaria
performers and house functional
outsourcing so people who are
outsourcing either development or
testing or ops these individual
functions we find that elite performers
almost never do that
like performers do it much more often
and actually our misguided performance
with the highest users of that kind of
functional outsourcing yeah I think
there's two things that that makes me
think of the small batches so how can
you control the amount waiting too long
between releases and having a fast
iteration cycle that happens we found
that to be true at Google and you know
if we go back to this cycle of
continuous improvement where we're
trying to add in automation and insight
I could see how that outsourcing would
be a challenge are people looking at the
same data are they having access to make
good decisions and exchange information
between each other can they even talk to
each other yeah and change the way they
work and collaborate effectively right
right interesting one we probably would
probably both talk about any ways in
which one can drive cultural change for
DevOps well we've mentioned some of them
I think one of my principles to come
back to within teams or where you run
into obstacles is where does the trust
start to break down and I think having a
strong culture that includes some of the
principles that we shared with today
they really have to be lived and you can
come back to you know at Google we can
use post-mortems to look at where did
things start to break down between the
humans were we not it was our piece of
data that was missing did someone not
have access to that information did we
not have a common understanding around
uptime what uptime was and how were we
not how are the that was a team not kind
of coming to the coming to the to the
outage or the issue that was coming up
with all of that information in mind so
we all are responsible for upholding
culture and when we see it start to
break down we all have to raise our hand
and say what can we do better next time
how can we help each other and help
build the trust back up yeah and you
have disaster recovery testing exercises
again yeah dirt testing yes where we
deliberately try and force things to go
down to see where we might have gaps in
our response
in our practices thanks for bringing
that up yeah I know it's still a
crippled Christian and talk about that
in the past that was amazing yeah great
practices within SRE okay I think we're
kind of out of time here pretty much by
fast yeah we will I know there are more
questions we will make sure they get
responded to on the platform I wanted to
say thank you to everyone for coming
today thank you so much to jazz and
a-team adora stay tuned for the next
session advanced service data processing
in cloud data pho thank you